si agnès varda on dit souvent que le
réel fait son cinéma
alors inutile de ressortir ses films qui
réclame d'ailleurs des droits que l'on
n'a pas vous prenez le mot rue daguerre
d'eilat au nom plutôt des images de la
vraie vie glané rue daguerre la rue où
agnès a fait sa vie est tournée c'est
faux documentaire nous sommes deux
soeurs nées sous le signe des gémeaux
arlette n'en fait qu'à sa tête ait
choisi de s'appeler agnès après une
naissance à bruxelles et lille
adolescence à cette période un peu floue
pour nous à nier ce fait la mise au
point de son point de vue derrière un
objectif photo pendant dix années elle
est photographe au tnp de jean vilar
puis c'est le déclic pourquoi pas
s'essayer à l'image animée
elle qui n'a vu que cinq films dans sa
jeune vie en 1954 son premier long
métrage la pointe-courte impressionne la
jeune barda vol alors l'avant-garde à
nouvelle vague en mai la nouvelle
réalisatrice elle surfe sur les vagues
d'à côté cléo de 5 à 7 son deuxième
succès clarifie son style
une promenade en 90 minutes en temps
réel qui se transforme peu à peu en
promenade surnaturel plus de 30
documentaires surréaliste le bonheur
sans toit ni loi où jacquot de nantes
des documenteurs comme elle aime les
nommer qui rendent hommage aux fruits de
la vie la meije l'aspirateur dans la
coface que c'est dur de bridge c'est
dans l'envers du décor qu'agnès est
installé maintenant à nous de prendre le
temps de la rencontre et à commencer par
le temps d'un café
mais voilà votre café
[Musique]